hey what's up guys my name is a Jonah
welcome to episode 30 of game
programming so yesterday or actually not
yesterday the day before last episode we
took a look at creating this random
method which actually didn't do anything
but what it did is it finalized our
rendered tile method so now this render
tile method is actually ready to you
know render something so today we're
actually gonna take a look at how we
actually call this render tile method
now it's kind of hard to sort of explain
this we are an example but I want to try
my best because I want good I really
want you guys sort of get the logic of
this but the thing is in our level class
right and specifically in our random
level class what happens is we generate
a random tile and then the idea is over
here you'll see we've got our towel fold
and we've got a class called tile and
this this tile class has its own render
method so a lot of you guys might be
like hang on a minute so how does
rendering specific tiles actually work
and that's sort of what we're going to
talk about today so how does rendering
tiles work it's quite simple all right
every tile renders itself okay every
single tile renders itself tiles
rendered themselves there is no method
in level which actually says all right
rendered this tile here
no it calls the tile that needs to be
rendered and the actual tile renders
itself not from a level not the screen
class the level basically what the level
does is it compiles a list an ArrayList
of tiles we might not actually using
ArrayList for that so don't be don't
hold me too strict to my arm to my
terminology but the level holds a list
of all the tiles in our send the win it
render in our scene in our map whatever
you know game do we need to render it
basically it just manages that list so
in other words as you can imagine when
we move our character somewhere I'll
probably just bring up a game to help
explain this more if weight is if we're
moving our our screen somewhere right
it's continually updating up that list
because as we lose as we lose this tile
here okay it's gone now
as we lose that tile we need to replace
it you know with another tile on this
site because that's sort of how these
scrolling games work right we only see
what's on the screen so as soon as we
move one tile total to the left for
example right there's a new tile there
that needs to get rented and this is
just running out like really fast right
now but anyway um yeah the point is like
when we when we move to a different part
of the map there's a new like that's
there's new tiles that actually need to
be rendered on the screen and that's
what the level class does it organizes
and manages which tiles actually need to
be rendered now what actually draws
these pixels on the screen is the tile
class because the tile class calls the
random method which activates this
specific rendered tile method in the
screen class and then draws the pixels
onto the screen so in other words I just
said the tile draws pixel on pixels onto
the screen really screen the screen
class draws pixels on the screen but
what I meant was the tile class is what
gives the official command to actually
render so the code that actually works
is over here so in this grass I'll
remember this is an abstract class um
I'm not going to do it today but we're
going to make these classes abstract
eventually I just want to take like a
whole episode to explain what abstract
means but the point is what I mean is
this tile class will actually never be
ran okay this is like a template for all
the subclasses that have tile is a
superclass all right at that extend tile
so like grass tile for example extends
tile right but this tile class is never
going to be run same same with the level
except I'm not gonna make the level
class abstract will be ever just because
I might actually use it hang on
whoo sorry about that just sneezed um
all right I think that's the first
episode it up today is that well it's
like it's really hot today as well some
it's like 42 degrees and in case you
guys don't know that all right it's 42
group it's 42 degrees Celsius sir whew
I'm 42 see in such 107 degrees
Fahrenheit 107 degrees Fahrenheit is
what I'm dealing with right now sir
that's why I sneeze I've always sneeze
when it's really hot anyway back to this
so yeah again the level class I might
actually use it for something but it's
all class is just template so we go into
the specific tile that we want to render
for example the grass tile in this case
and this is where we actually do our
render stuff which is what we're going
to do right now so what I'm going to do
is this is something you can do in
Eclipse as well is you can just click
and drag this tab and you can sort of
like move it somewhere so like for
example right over here right and this
will actually like bring up two tabs
like that so in other words if you guys
don't have like two monitors or
something on you know dual monitors you
don't have that stuff then you can um
you know you kind of have to deal with
having one monitor like I am right now
actually because I'm long story but the
point is you can sort of display two
things at once so I'll probably just
limit my screen capture that to these
two so you can see it's very useful
because we're going to go to our screen
class we can see exactly the parameters
that we need for render tiled work so
right over here we're just going to call
the rennet our method very simple so
we'll it's green class here which
actually um yeah okay let's call it
don't worry about it I just had a bit of
a I just I sort of got confused every
minute all right so screen dot and again
this render tile method that's right
here it's actually really useful for
explaining having two displays are
parallel to each other
so rent a tile right Brenda tile and
then we need the x position the Y
position and the type of tile that we're
rendering so in other words the x
position is just going to be X and the y
position the Y position is going to be Y
so that's pretty simple X Y and then the
tile that we're rendering which is what
it asks for right here
it's just as grass tile and because
we're in this grass hut right now we
simply type this that's it that is that
is as simple as it is now stop because
that's actually not as simple as it is
the reason it's not as simple as it is
is because these inputs aren't actually
going to be in a format that we can
actually put into here they're not going
to be in per pixel format actually I am
is think
yeah I mean no no sorry they're not
going to be in tile format they're going
to be in pixel format so we'll actually
have to apply mathematical operators to
this sounds so formal I don't know how
else but it will actually have to UM you
know play around with these numbers a
bit to have them line up properly
because at the moment they're in pixels
and over here where else infotile
positions not pixel positions so we'll
talk about that when we actually you
know see what this gives us because I
sort of like showing you guys what goes
wrong so you guys understand better how
it works and why I do what I do
ah but yeah so that that's it and again
when when it go when it comes to tile
and it tries to look up detail that's
right the pixels is going to go to the
tile class which is this then it's going
to go to the sprite which is here sprite
and then it's going to go into sprite
and it's going to go over here into the
pixels and it's going to grab that a
sprite thing and and read the pixels
from there and display them onto our
screen so yeah that is episode 30 of
game programming I hope you enjoyed this
and I will see you guys I'll see you
guys next time so if you did enjoy it
please little like button maybe give it
a favorite and I'll see you guys next
time goodbye
you